combinaisons masques et machines
philippe va passer les prochaines
minutes à désinfecter un bus dont le
service est terminée il pulvérise un
virus il dans une cinquantaine de
véhicules chaque jour du haut vers le
bas puisque ça à ses sens et pulvérisé
donc de fines particules de produits de
façon à ce que ce dernier repose sur
l'echez fallait dossier il écoute les
rampes maintient que pourrait utiliser
un passager lorsque celui ci monte dans
le car c'est un produit qui est tenu
d'être efficace pendant 24 heures et
ainsi de suite
une désinfection jusqu alors inédite les
transporteurs yvelinois s'y sont mis dès
l'apparition de l'épidémie ski bus le
complète avec des gestes barrières la
mobilisation est associé avec un
nettoyage manuel jusqu'à la semaine
dernière ont monté par la porte arrière
et on descendait par les portes arrière
et depuis ce matin on a remis une
circulation normale dans le véhicule au
monde par la porte avant et on descend
par les portes arrière et on a condamné
un siège sur deux pour faire respecter
la distanciation nécessaire et on a
indiqué au sol aussi par le moyen de
petits stickers les espaces
un maître pour que chacun puisse avoir
une indication elle la capacité des
véhicules est réduite à une vingtaine de
places 6 qui bus maintient aujourd'hui
95% de son offre la fréquentation n'est
toujours pas revenu à la normale
seulement 25 % des usagers ont repris le
chemin des transports en commun